is this the new normal for you or is it
all still kind of a bit mad
you step by now yes sure why not yeah
well you were at the Grammys recently
was it last weekend or the weekend
before um yes sure it was on Sunday and
uh I went and I was nominated and I had
one call yeah
this is the Grammys during a little I
was sitting in my chair but they have
like these people who come and sit in
the seats when people off to their
Peter poo
and then uh can I go up and then I
wasn't I didn't do anything
I'll either came up to me and said damn
oh I'll take this seat now and I went
I went
whatever do you mean
so this is your seat and I went listen
I know I didn't win the Grammy but I
thought I'd be allowed to stay to the
end